i think the reason why this was okay to
scare uh to share
is because
it doesn't look real
it looks like it's green screen this is
a movie it is a movie it's like i don't
even think our brains understood what
was happening have you ever seen a cliff
just fall off i've seen avalanches i
haven't seen a rock i've never seen it
separate itself never like it's unreal i
didn't know it was possible yeah no you
see glaciers you know how people like
watch those things
they cause the waves but that makes
sense because ice melts you think okay
that could happen with a glacier you
don't think a rock melts
yeah it was just so weird like was there
a earthquake or something like have they
found the cause i think it was there was
like a lot of rain or something that
they thought kind of loosened things up
and then if there's like a one minute
video where apparently they're speaking
in spanish and portuguese i don't know
but people are warning the guys that are
filming are warning everybody like go
get out of there get out of there
for like a minute
and nobody really seems to move and then
you see it kind of move a little bit and
then people start trying to get out of
the way but it's too late watch real
quick
oh my god oh my god
look at this one this one boat
son that one boat right there the red
boat sees it's happening he floors it he
probably saved every [__] i
don't know if anybody died that was on
that boat but they would literally all
be dead that white right
yeah that white boat right there that's
just stalled out they're dead everybody
on that boat is dead guaranteed yeah
insane
insane and some people jumped off i
wonder if jumping off the boat would
help you i was trying to think of how i
would survive it yeah i would have
jumped off if you're not really if
you're right under i'm assuming that's
just but if you're like a little to the
side
do you jump off i mean because the rock
is gonna sink it's so dense so
you've gotta jump off and you gotta dive
as deep as you possibly can yeah yeah
dive is deep because
the rock is gonna hit the water and it's
gonna be stopped like you know how you
can shoot a bullet into a like not a cup
of water but there's a certain amount of
water and the just the water itself will
stop it yeah they do these experiments i
don't know how deep maybe a bucket or
something like that but a bullet won't
go no matter how fast it blows going
water's really dense yeah it's super
dense so it's going to stop the rock to
a certain extent or at least stop it
from going so fast it's going to kill
you on impact right so i'm like diving
and then i'm swimming if i know it's
falling right on me i'm diving i'm
swimming down as fast as i [__] can
yeah
the boulder you're gonna have to go 20
30 feet you can't do it that way and i
assume a boulder would just sink to the
bottom
that [__] just drowns you at the bottom
that's true and then you got to try to
come out of it suck you in could it
create like a pressure zone 100 it's
like titanic oh yeah remember when they
jump off the boat and they're like yo
the second we jump off just starts
swimming yeah because when the boat
sinks it's to take you down with it yeah
yeah yeah like there are people who
probably survived the impact
and then we're sucked down with it yeah
that's insane yeah foul crazy luck so
like what happens
is this type of tourism done
well the crazy thing is i feel like
stuff like this happens often maybe not
often but like frequently just like
around the world like rock formations
are just like slide and fall and there's
just never people there you know what i
mean yeah so like this might happen all
the time we just don't really know
yeah because i don't cliff got that way
somehow yeah yeah but the way that they
explain it to us is that it's like
erosion over millions of years yeah like
you ever see these models never in the
model do you see just a section of the
cliff fall off one year right they make
it seem like oh wind was blowing against
it and there was some sand and it slowly
carved into this shape nah fam yeah that
that thing fell apart in chunks probably
yeah
yeah they said there was extremely heavy
rain in the area and a dike overflowed
at an iron ore mine whoa dude you just
want it come on come on
whoa dude you really wanted to just say
that might cause this
really yeah so dyke was just standing on
the end of it and that's what happened
dyches heavy
then brazilian dykes don't play around
bro i guess not yeah they are not
playing around what do you think was
happening you think she was doing like a
little tick tock video at the end of it
she was doing her little dance and then
just that weight that pressure bro
them co-morbidities
then comorbidities cause that rock to
fall
you